[Music]
marita is with us in syracuse new york
hi maria how are you
hello rachel thank you so much for
talking with me today
sure can you speak directly into your
phone it's pretty muffled
uh yes is that better yes perfect yes
thank you
all right awesome um so i have a
question um about
student loans uh yay i have many
emotions about what biden declared today
um but i'll try and get to the point uh
my husband and i were in our early 20s
we have 2
375
left to pay off on our student loans we
have worked so hard to get to this point
now biden's declared that he can just
forgive it at some point but we know
there's a period of time before that's
going to happen would it be the right
thing to do out of principle to just pay
it off on our own
or should we apply for forgiveness once
that application becomes available to us
write a check and pay it off
don't wait okay
don't wait
the emotion here is so is so mixed about
the call today and and what they
announced
and
and i think the heart behind it is
relief well
we can probably go all around but i
think there's an element of it that is
to relieve people and you guys don't
need relief because you have the money
and
you've got i mean and there and there is
a personal responsibility thing with all
of this too that you guys you know
signed this
uh and your names are on it and
uh the idea of taking money from the
government when you have it i just don't
i can't i can't uh
that doesn't say well done so well with
me so
i've got to check and pay it off don't
wait on them
i'm a nice that's a nice way of saying
it
you um
you already knew that that was what you
wanted to do because it's who you are by
the way you phrased your question
and so it makes it very easy for us to
just agree with you and say yeah
yeah i would do that
um
uh you know it's not immoral
um
for someone to take the relief that is
being offered
but
there is a
uh
a moral obligation that you borrowed the
money
and to pay it back is not a it is a
values-based decision
uh even though you quote don't have to
unquote
it's a values-based decision
and and
you know
so you know on a macro level on a
nationwide level on a
big scope um
somewhere we have to remind people that
the money comes
from the government
comes from somewhere
and the 300
billion dollars
with a b a billion is a thousand million
that is 300 000
million
that
the president is strutting around proud
that he just added to the taxpayers
burden
if you are a taxpayer
and 48 percent of you are not
in america today a federal income tax
taxpayer
but for those of us that are our burden
was just increased by three hundred
thousand million
so that you could get ten thousand
dollars in debt forgiveness
um i'm happy for you if you got your
debt forgiveness
i really don't want bad things for you i
want good things for you and i'm not
angry with you you didn't do anything
out there if you got debt forgiveness
but
the absurdity of this political move as
a hail mary to try to get back in the
graces of the good of the voters before
the midterms in a in a in a presidential
administration that is a complete
economic failure
it's just
infuriating
and it's all put on the backs of your
grandchildren because it's all added to
the deficit
three 30 trillion dollars in debt
already
and we add 300 000 million
to that in student loan forgiveness
while we continue to make student loans
and this is just
it's just intellectually dishonest
to continue to make the loans and on the
one hand and then turn around forgive
them on the next
because the next call we're going to be
getting
that we're going to get this call
because it's already running through
some of your heads
i've got 26 thousand dollars in student
loan debt president biden just forgave
10 i'm going to wait on him to forgive
the rest is that okay
even though there's no announcement of
that or or indication of that or
promise of that or
but you know once you've opened the
spigot
you know folks are gonna con expect you
to continue to open the spigot like
trump issued by bucks during the trump
dollars during the covid and then
another set and then biden and bucks
came out and biden bucks and biden bucks
so once the once the all of your coveted
problems were going to be solved by the
government instead of by your own hand
then you now are waiting on
these biden bucks to come through after
the trump bucks
after the biden bucks after the trump
bucks and it just keeps going and going
and going and going because you've
become begun to look at washington dc as
your source
when we are getting those questions
and we've gotten that question for over
a decade i feel like every politician
makes some kind of debt for student loan
forgiveness
well you know it was the fringe it was
elizabeth warren and aoc it was the
french wackos that were suggesting it at
first and then it got a little bit more
mainstream and this president is so far
left
so far much a socialist in his and his
approach to things that um
you know he had it on a campaign promise
took him 18 months in office to come
through with the campaign promise but
the idea is that during during the 18
months but also
even just the idea of student loan
forgiveness that's been floating around
for almost a decade we've heard that
term because because in
very small pockets right you see
different things
um
but and we and we get those calls even
then like this is
actual facts on paper that it's
happening
but even just the idea to your points
floats in people's heads and when that
seed is planted
it's this idea that i'm gonna just sit
back turns you into a trust fund baby
and there's a
yeah
yeah i mean if you're sick if you're if
your dad is 60 years old and he's got 10
million dollars and you don't work much
and you want to just sit around wait on
him to die
for you to have a life
because you're going to get it because
you're going to inherit 10 million
it's the same dadgum thing i'm sitting
around waiting on i guess someone else
to fix my life
yes right the mindset is the same but i
think the feeling of debts and the
weight that debt carries on families
though is different than i just want to
be lazy like you know what i'm saying i
agree so they might yeah i get what
you're saying but also i'm like man
there's like this but when you when you
say okay i'm not gonna deal with this
right
and i'm gonna let someone else i'm gonna
i'm not gonna deal with this i'm gonna
i'm gonna wait on someone else to deal
with it and that's not morita and what's
interesting too we talk about this all
the time on the show of how money your
habits within money
are a lot of different habits in other
areas of your life
and so it's fascinating too when if you
become passive
with your money sitting back and letting
other people take it like
are you then passive in your career your
passion in your marriage and your
parents like what healthier because
you're one person you talk about this a
lot like you're an like integer it's a
whole number we are to have integrity
you are a whole person so you can't take
one part of your life and say
i'm going to be like this this and this
wait right like we think we can
compartmentalize so much and we can't we
are one person
and so even what that does i mean i
don't have the science to back it but i
am curious it's impossible to be highly
ambitious organized and disciplined
in your money
and uh be completely opposite of that in
every other area of your life it's it's
or be or be highly ambitious and
disciplined in your career but be
completely undisciplined and physical
you know because the opposite is true
and the opposite is true which we hear
all the time that people are like oh my
gosh my spouse and i like we got out of
debt and it changed our marriages we
started communicating you know we even
hear health like i lost weight right
like all these other things fall into
place and so our marriage got better
feed planted of being passive in life
it's just hard i mean i think it just
affects other areas too so we just you
got to be careful you got to be careful
margaret thatcher said it well the
problem with socialism is eventually run
away run out of other people's money to
give away
it's a problem